[Music]
I'm out here you like to say everybody
knows everything what if the truth was
nobody knows anything I got a feeling
today is today today's the day I can
feel it this time I can feel him
good to see you John it took so long to
find you what do you say say I'm not
gone John anymore it's funny huh why
would you want to find me my husband has
never seen your face you were right
about him he's violent with him what's
this this is a scratch it'll scratch huh
I want you to take him out on your boat
and drop them in the ocean for the
Sharks
they say she came all the way to see you
yes she's about temptation it's right
and wrong in Plymouth everybody knows
everything love that kind of a big day
tomorrow
I know all about your big day it's like
everybody knows something I know how you
explain that deal will you have yourself
a good day now and do what's right okay
deliver me I'm impatient
are you going to take him out you're not
writing your money the wife says you're
being a little difficult there's
something wrong
sometimes we do bad things for good
reasons
[Music]
you